jetzt ist es passiert der brh exit hat
sein erstes prominentes opfer thomas
cook das älteste reiseunternehmen der
welt ist insolvent ja unter anderem weil
das pfund dank drexhage so schwach ist
und sich reisen für briten massiv
verteuern
bittere woche also für boris johnson
diesen lebenden blondinenwitz zumal ja
auch noch das höchste gericht
großbritanniens seine parlaments
zwangspause für rechtswidrig erklärt hat
jeder normale premierminister würde
jetzt zurücktreten aber das betrifft ihn
ja nicht
diese woche hat er vor der uno in new
york den dreck sind mit einer
griechischen sage erklärt
bei boris johnson hat der radler
übrigens das gehirn herausgepickt und es
ist leider nicht wieder nachgewachsen
diese woche beleidigter man das
zurückgeholte unterhaus in london als
und otis zombie parlament ausgerechnet
boris ich meine dieser von keinem von
keinem gewählte möchtegern diktator da
war aber direkt wieder stimmung in der
alten bude
[Applaus]
was hast du mit drei farben dieser
displays geben ist nicht frei minister
der tagebau see
[Applaus]
cool oder
für so was muss ich hier zu lande drei
stunden hat er zwei gucken die haben das
im parlament ja genau wie sein geistiger
zwilling trump 5 johnson auf den
rechtsstaat und behauptet den
sogenannten volkswillen durchzuboxen
dabei das britische volk nie für
nothilfe stimmt immer sehr gespannt ob
es weiter wagt die arme alte queen für
seine schmutzigen tricks zu missbrauchen
könnte mir denken dass die stimmung
zwischen den beiden doch merklich
abgekühlt ist in den letzten tagen oder
wie man auf der insel sagen würde
majesty ist not amused
der mister johnson johnson komiker dirk
bach sche tiebreaks it sollten sie mich
noch einmal anrufen wo personal vom
tower bridge werde ich sie persönlich an
der tower bridge aufhängen an wenn meine
hausbank philipp 3uk und dann nach hause
bist du
das geld hilft
ja
hat das immer gedacht die sind nämlich
nur so niedlich aus wenn du dir wird das
voll die gangster [ __ ] aber zurück zur
thomas cook freunde denn deren pleite
betrifft ja leider auch uns deutsche
wird dann weiter um unsere arme
traditions- fluglinie condor el condor
pasa lateinisch für der geier ist pleite
noch nicht denn jetzt gibt es ja 380
millionen euro staatshilfe von peter
altmaier
quasi als kleine condor überraschung ja
das ist eine gute entscheidung gute
entscheidung kondo freut sich und onkel
peter auch ich freue mich sehr für die
betroffenen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter ich freue mich sehr für die
flugpassagiere denen wir auf diese art
und weise eine perspektive geben können
ich freue mich den fluggästen die
perspektive zu geben vielleicht
irgendwann nach hause zu kommen wollen
viele gar nicht andere geschichte
tolle nachricht jedenfalls für rund 5000
mitarbeiter sicher man könnte auch
fragen warum den 26.000 menschen die
zuletzt in der windenergie rausgeflogen
sind keiner geholfen hat aber was
arbeiten die auch in einer
klimafreundlichen branche wichtig ist
dass wir jetzt unsere touristen
rausholen
das ist natürlich eine gigantische
operation wenn man sich vorstellt dann
muss eine stadt mit 150.000 einwohnern
praktisch so groß wie paderborn etwa
zurückgeholt werden
wieso sollte man paderborn zurückholen
will künftig in paderborn beck ist ja
tatsächlich wurden viele urlauber böse
erwischt von der thomas cook pleite
manche hängen immer noch fest an der
costa del insolvenz und auch weil die
hotels angst haben auf ihren kosten
sitzen zu bleiben gab es diese woche
dramatische szenen wie hier in der
domrep schreie gewalt bilder die man
sonst nur sieht wenn ein buffet das
tiramisu alle ist wahnsinn
anderswo kommst du vom strand total
verschwitzt und eingecremt und dann
lassen sich die säcke vom hotel nicht
mehr auf dein zimmer auch so du bezahlst
noch mal tausende von deutschen sind
betroffen auch der kollege ulrich von
heesen hängt seit tagen fest am
flughafen gran canaria und hofft jetzt
dass ich irgendeine billig airline nach
hause fliegt ulrich wie läuft es denn
will
hören sie auf zu lagernden freundliche
raus ich habe den schlimmsten fehler
meines lebens gemacht ich habe eine
pauschalreise gebucht wie so ein ganz
gewöhnlicher langsam wie eine von den
trottel hier hinter mir jemand muss mich
hier raus fliegen
es ist mit dem zdf privatjet den hat
freitags immer carmen nebel samstag
markus lanz sonntag sorry
niemand redet hier mit uns wir kriegen
nichts zu essen nicht zu trinken wie die
tiere sind uralte engländer der ist kurz
vom kollabieren und dann essen bei ihm
auf so hilft er uns eine weitere woche
zu überleben das ist ja furchtbar und
schuld ist thomas cook oder der braig
sind oder wer schuld ist die scheiß
billigfliegerei damit schicken sich die
firma selbst ins knie ein ryanair ticket
kostete 2018 im schnitt 37 euro noch mal
sechs prozent weniger als im vorjahr und
alle machen mit beim fröhlichen dumping
sogar die noble lufthansa bei eur wenig
sparen sie jetzt an den kosten in
zukunft nicht mehr eine tüte pro sitz
sondern eben nur noch eine tüte
freigegeben
eine orange sprecherin begründete das in
der bild zeitung mit umweltschutzgründen
nur noch eine kotztüte pro reihe macht
es beim nächsten mal kurz sich dem euro
hat einfach auf seine proteste uniform
aus umweltschutzgründen ja ich denke die
deutschen buchen immer mehr flüge trotz
klima flugschau da muss doch was hängen
bleiben da eben nicht es gibt schlicht
zu viele flugzeuge am markt deshalb
preiskampf und deswegen machen airlines
mit dem ticketverkauf teilweise verlust
die verdienen nur noch geld weil jedes
glas wasser jeder koffer extra kostet
oder weil sie unterwegs bescheuerte
rubbel lose verkaufen um was machen wir
da jetzt ganz einfach wir erfinden die
zeitmaschine und reisen zurück in die
60er
ich weiß noch wie das fliegen war damals
man durfte rauchen
die schleim deck dich dem fliegenden
restaurant sie virtuell ist es sich wohl
sein
es gab richtig ist es im flugzeug
ich passe gilberto die ryanair tool gibt
uns was zu futtern
ich glaube es ist ein ganzes ende hat
mich durch zdf guten tag könnte ich sie
für ein abo des heute show youtube
kanals begeistern schließt gefälligst
ein abo ab sofort